you want to do when you solve a system
of three variables three equations is
you want to try to pick one of the
variables to eliminate either the X's
the Y's or disease in this particular
example let's go ahead and eliminate the
X's so what I'm going to do is in order
to you know combine two of the equations
together so that the XS cancel I'm gonna
have to multiply this top equation by
two the second equation by one so let's
go ahead and do that so I'm just gonna
say times two times one so if we do that
we get 2x plus 2y plus 2z equals four
and then for the second one that's just
going to be a negative x minus 3y minus
Z equals negative eight if we add
straight down I'm sorry this is a
negative 2x so if we add straight down
these X's are going to cancel and you
can see that we get negative y plus Z
equals negative four so we've used the
first two equations now we want to use
the third equation as well we can
combine it with the first one or with
the second one but we want to make sure
we use all three so what I'm going to do
here is I'm going to multiply this top
equation by three negative three and the
bottom one just I'm going to leave as it
is so if we multiply this top one by
negative three we get negative 3x
negative 3y and negative 3z equals
negative six when we add straight down
you can see the XS cancel we get Y minus
Z equals four and so I bring that over
here Y minus Z equals four we're down to
two variables two equations what I'm
going to do now is we're going to try to
eliminate the Y's or the Z's you can see
if I add straight down the Y's are going
to cancel that gives us zero does these
are going to cancel that gives us zero
and the 4 and negative 4 cancel that
gives us 0 we have 0 equals 0 this is
what they call an identity you know
these are identical and that tells us
that we have a general solution it's not
just going to be one point where all
three of these equations coincide or
intersect so what we do at this point is
we pick one of the variables and we set
it equal to like a for example like
another variable another constant so
what we're going to do is we're going to
say let's just take this bottom one
equation let's just say let Z
equal some quantity a and if we put a
back in for Z we've got Y minus a equals
four if I add a to both sides I get y
equals a plus four and so now we know
what Z is in terms of a we know what y
is in terms of a now we just have to
find out what x is in terms of a let's
go back to this top equation here we've
got X plus instead of Y let's put what y
equals a plus four instead of Z let's
put what Z equals which is a okay so
plus a and that equals two so now if we
solve for x we have x plus 2 a plus four
equals two if we subtract 2 a and four
from both sides to get X by itself we
get x equals let's see these cancel
these cancel we get negative 2 a minus 2
so now we have x y&z all in terms of a
so we have X as negative 2 a minus 2y
equals a plus 4 and Z is equal to a and
this is your general solution if you
want to find some points that are part
of that general solution you can set a
equal to 0 for example that would give
you one of the points on that general
solution or if a equals 1 equals 2 etc
but this is a way of expressing the
general solution in terms of another
variable in this case we call that
variable a so great job if you want to
see another problem involving systems of
equations specifically how to solve for
an equation of a parabola given three
points on the parabola check out the
video right there that I did and I'll
see you over there